for
too
open the meeting of the Health and Human
Services oversight committee for Friday
October 27
role representative Pearson
here representative King
here Senator
gray representative Murphy
representative McDonald representative
Weber here representative Edwards here
representative Merchant here Senator
rosenwall Senator avard here the chair
received requests absons from Rosen wal
McDonald um
and Murphy and I also did from
representative Edwards but he decided to
come
anyway
I will uh entertain a motion to accept
the previous
minutes gray move second I'll second it
but I have a comment you now we may
comment okay um I I I don't know if our
regular minute format handles this of
course I was absent last time um but it
it it bugs me to not do my job uh I I
was out on a medical FL so if there is a
a way to condition the kind of absence
or or qualify it I I'd appreciate
it okay if the clerk would add that and
I gave you those who had already called
in with excused
discussion seeing none all in favor of
abstain I was not here
same okay so you cannot find any errors
in the last meeting
then no I
cannot I have no idea what the rules are
on these committees but generally
speaking house members aren't allowed to
abstain from things it it may be fine I
don't know I wasn't here either but I'm
going to vote Yes because I think
they're probably okay okay so if if the
rules allow it representative Merchant
abstains if they don't he vot votes yes
just as a a point the Senate operates
under Robert's Rules you guys under a
different set of rules but Robert's
Rules would allow you to vote in favor
or against am minutes whether you were
there or not based on your knowledge of
what went on either through you know
hearsay watching a video or whatever so
uh I certainly have no problem with them
voting or not voting as they choose Mr
chair I I because of Robert I will vote
yes thank you as it quaz I Robert I'll
vote Yes okay I like Bob I'll go yes
too I was given Masons for Christmas so
uh I'll have to reread that section but
I think we've approved the minutes uh
the nomination next item nomination of
Jay Gupta director of Pharmacy and
Integrative Health Harvard care in New
Hampshire is an adjunct member to serve
on the subcommittee of this group on
Alim disease and other related dementia
Mr gup to
here representative Merchant would you
speak to him as a fellow pharmacist I I
will
um Mr Gupta comes to us with an
extensive background both as a
pharmacist as well as somebody who
worked in the industry and he also has
spearheaded a lot of things at Harbor
care dealing with Pharmacy coverage and
working with patients and trying to
allow them to get coverage that they
need drastically so he's very first in
the issue of trying to understand the
pharmacy world and trying to migrate
patients
from the need of drug therapy and
finding ways to get that taken care of
by the payers or finding sources for
them to do the I think we get into
Alzheimer's we're going to have the same
issue because a lot of the drugs are
expensive and a lot of the ways in which
patients will access the pharmaceutical
care we've predicated upon that access
point so I therefore bring him to our
committee as adjunct to the committee
subcommittee thank you uh this was a
subcommittee that is on the in in the
law books and in the seven years I've
been in the house had not met but people
had come to me and said we'd like to
crank it up again so we did uh there
were a few people that some of us felt
should have been named as regular
members but the people who got named to
their slots were equally good so what to
do well they could just come they could
just show up if they wanted to but I
wanted to recognize um pharmacist Gap
and also Dr Jeffrey
Solway in a little special way so they
are not voting members but they will be
participating members to the degree the
chair um allows that so that's the
backstory to
that um next item and I'm going to ask
if
uh I think it's the chair's nomination
but if you'd like to vote chair's nomin
yeah I think so then we don't need a
vote but had it not been would you have
voted yes I certainly I thought so next
if um attorney Edwards would explain
what the next section is please
Williams you
said did you Williams I said Edwards but
I meant Williams you both knew
that chairman parison members of the
committee we worked together for so long
that I absolutely knew exactly who he
was referring to um so thank you very
much I tried really hard not to insult
you by calling you representative this
time I don't have a response but with
that um we I I want to thank you for
this opportunity to be a resource to the
committee um uh chairman Pearson uh
working uh along with the Department
were able to identify legislation that
pass pass this um past session that uh
includes uh items that were either for
new reports or for Action items for for
this committee I Look to um represent
Edwards as the chair division three who
very thoughtfully during the budget
process identified certain areas where
uh the subject matter that is gerain to
this committee would have some type of
either a reporting item or some type of
review or review and approval so what
you have as part of your agenda when you
see it is a kind of a reduced down
version of the number of items that were
past the session I will say since I've
been doing this I've never seen four
pages worth you do have a a more uh
annotated document that gives you the
background over the types of items that
have been added for this committee's
review but certainly uh you've met a
benchmark of quite a few items that have
been passed this past session so I don't
know how you would like to handle it
because there's only 15 minutes to
review all the items of for particular
questions from the committee on you know
certain items just to scan over and
certainly uh if I not able to respond I
know we do have members uh from the
Department in the audience who could
also uh participate but today is a
review uh of the items that were passed
it's not the actual review themselves
those are being calendared for uh review
by this committee or on on the agenda
there is one item I would point out that
director Wendy Alman uh with our
long-term supports and Services the
Bureau of elderly and Adult Services I
will be here today to present the plan
as it relates to an awareness campaign
around Alzheimer's and and related
dementia and so that is one of the items
on this list that is scheduled for your
review
today some of these will naturally be
showing up on our schedule our agenda
correct yes naturally and since that's
the case do we we simply wait for them
to show up uh and is what we're now
doing looking for the ones that might
not naturally show up to ask them to
show up is that what you
suggest I I don't believe that's what
I'm suggesting because I think this
committee has done a a very good job of
keeping a matrix of all of the reporting
requirements we certainly uh do add
those um it's interesting though that is
a good question uh for the chair uh on
there is no requirement on many of the
reports to actually present uh but we
have historically done that and so we've
had members not only from the department
but you'll also see on the list of the
new requirements that there's other
agencies like the uh um in this case the
Department of Labor has now been charged
with workplace safety in clinical
settings they're added to the list um
you also have the office of professional
life insurance certification I believe
that there's an reporting item for them
or at least a review item uh for for
those
groups so are you suggesting we read
down the list and when we see something
interesting
what however you'd like to handle the
review
I um yes please suggestion thank you my
suggestion would be and thank you very
much for this is a resource because it's
really useful so thanks to both of you
who generated it that perhaps we could
save time by taking it away with us and
coming back next month with any
suggestions about action items for
anything that doesn't fall into the into
our natural rotation but Mr chairman I
also wanted to make a Express a concern
because uh our agendas have become
Fuller and Fuller and fitting it all
into two hours once a month is
apparently become harder and harder and
I don't know
whether we ought as a committee and not
necessarily today to think about either
setting a longer time block or meeting
more often because I'm really worried
that we have a huge docket of really
important things to go over and I don't
want any of them to get short shrift so
I just throw that out as a suggestion
once once we add these onto our already
full docket um I'm I'm concerned that
we're going to fall farther and farther
behind or we're not going to be as
thorough as we have traditionally been
representative Weber was one of my good
mentors when I first became a committee
chairman and she's continuing to do so
so might I suggest uh what do you think
representative Edwards uh thank you Mr
chair and I I I endorse what uh
representative Weber just said U uh I
was just going to suggest that as a as a
rule uh that the depart since the
department knows which of these areas
that oversight has some accountability
for getting involved with that a
management by exception approach be
initiated so that if we're out of cycle
from a report and something seems to be
going wrong or a skew that we ought to
be aware of to go ahead and take the
initiative to to bring it to the
committee and let us know that that that
would be one thing that I would want to
do and then I I have a second comment if
you'll allow follow up okay at at this
point would it be inappropriate if I
asked what I would hope to be a short
answer um uh regarding one of these
items like okay so um Mr Williams um hb2
on the healthc care workplace violence
prevention program um did what the
commissioner had asked we we um put into
suspense for this budget period DHHS is
obligation to basically provide some
leadership and some database work and
some other things um and when we did
that the intent and hope was was that
the private sector would stand up and
make it happen without the government
involved do you have any idea if the
private sector is stepping into that
vacuum and and chairman if I can respond
to represent Edward's question well on
on your first item that you you did
bring up I just wanted to respond uh
about bringing emergent issues or
bringing reports to this uh committee we
have historically worked very closely
with this committee uh and and certainly
those items as matter practice have been
brought before the committee so that's
this first item so great idea is
something that we've already been
adhering to the the next item is where
we are around this very important
workplace uh group and I know there's
members of the audience who are feeling
a gravitational poll who are not
necessarily with the Department uh that
work for perhaps hospitals and other
associations but you may recall in in
Senator gray uh you were very much
instrumental in the first bill that
created the workplace safety commission
and the concern that we had and the
reason why the original Bill had its
effective date pushed out was to allow
our agency to respond with building into
the budget the necessary resources to do
the data analytics that were required as
part of that proposal as the bill made
its way back through the legislative
process in this in the budget cycle and
working with division 3 and working with
you as the chair of that committee
represent Edwards we were able to work
very collaboratively with the Department
of Labor and they were more than
gracious to accept the responsibility to
having the work administratively
attached to them we certainly are an
important player particularly because we
do have institutions like New Hampshire
hospital Hamstead hospital um
residential treatment facilities and and
others that certainly we certainly
benefit uh from the work of that group
and the data to keeping our staff safe
uh but it's now housed with the
Department of Labor so that's one of the
items that I actually mentioned that
your new deliverables in terms of folks
coming before you have been expanded
well okay so as I summarize what you
just said is that DHHS has suspended
their leadership of this program it's
the it's been transferred informally
over to the Department of Labor and that
makes me think uh that we may need uh a
legislative tweak
and if we need a legislative tweak to
pin the row on labor um let me know and
and I I'll try to figure out how to do
that
tweak and chairman I I just wanted to
make sure I understood when you I think
I heard the word inally uh if if that
was the word and I apologize because
that I I it was actually formally done
as part of the legislation um that came
out through the budget process to
realign with the Department of Labor
from our agency however notwithstanding
all of that uh the commissioner uh Ken
Maryfield is certainly a wonderful
person to work with very collaboratively
with and we look forward to the
opportunity to continue working with him
this is an important commission for the
department and we do serve on the
commission we're active participants the
transfer however to the Department of
Labor because they deal with labor
issues and workplace safety issues that
it was better housed with them and we
really appreciate them stepping up uh I
do believe and I'd have to look back at
hb2 but I do believe there were some
additional resources either in hb2 or in
the operating budget that was provided
to support this program in the data
analytics and and again I know we have
people in the audience and but with the
brevity of time I probably shouldn't be
gravitationally pulling anybody up at
this moment from other outside entities
thank you counselor I the chair would
like to take up representative Weber's
suggestion that we look down this list
and ponder it for the next month and
talk in a 91a respectful manner amongst
ourselves that uh we could perhaps come
back with uh a few further
thoughts um also just before we get too
far away I want to thank um uh attorney
uh Williams because he's putting
suggested limits on time which is why we
ad adjourned last time right at 12:00
with a big agenda it's it's encouraging
us to time discipline and thank so thank
you for coming up yeah you're quite
welcome and ironically we are on time
even though I think my commentary went
maybe a little bit too long thank you
the other thing I wish to bring up
before I forget it this is triggered by
the nomination of somebody to a
subcommittee um I've been approached by
somebody saying there's other
subcommittees that are lurking in the
law somewhere that come out of DHHS
oversight committee that maybe want to
be reassembled and I'm quite open to
bringing that forward to this group just
if if uh the one I spoke to earlier has
anything further please speak to me
afterwards uh anybody else hearing this
um if there are other subcommittees that
should be meeting and you want to meet
me next
page um
DHHS Commissioners update
congratulations to my fellow fellow we
share Milbank Fellowship in Li it Public
Health I think it is something like that
yeah so my fellow fellow deput newly
appointed Deputy Commissioner
congratulations and with
her uh the man I affectionately called
Jersey Jeff who replaced Jersey Joe uh
we've got a good pipeline down there to
New Jersey and it's doing DCF a good
thing so welcome both of you great thank
you so much um for your kind words um
and the commissioner sends her regards
as well um and her regrets that she's
not able to be here today um you know
occasionally when you're in a in have
the privilege of being in a position of
executive leadership you post a job and
um an applicant comes along and you say
this is exactly the person we need for
this role right now um and I believe
that is what happened to us now six
seven years ago when Joe ribom came
along as dcyf director over the course
of 5 years um
transforming and I and I mean that
cliche word with no degree of um
overstatement our child welfare and
Juvenile Justice systems and with the
announcement of Joe moving on um to a
different role at a national level when
I received Jeff fler resume and I think
I responded in maybe five minutes um
which he kids me about a little bit now
um it was clear that this was exactly
the person to continue building on the
foundation um that has come before while
moving Us in um even more positive
directions for kids and families and so
um at your request wanted to give Jeff a
few minutes to introduce himself talk a
little bit about his vision um I want to
acknowledge traditionally um DCF has
actually reported up to Children's
oversight commission led by Senator
Carson and uh as its kind of oversight
body but part of the beauty of the
direction that um we've been headed with
DCF is that um the entire program the
efforts Jeff is now taking the Helm of
and leading are really um are really
understood in a in a paradigm that is
side by side with health and especially
Behavioral Health and so one of the best
um symbols of that has been Jeff at
Children's oversight which happened last
Friday sitting side by side with Kya Fox
our director of the division for
Behavioral Health co-presenting
co-leading um so much of what needs to
be integrated across the department to
um help families and kids get what they
need so so without further Ado I want to
introduce Jeff I'll just say by way of
um background he has nearly 40 years of
experience leading one of the nation and
really the world's um most respected
nonprofits the youth advocacy program
which um is entirely geared around
helping kids families get the services
they need and um in many cases in most
cases altogether avoid the need for um
acute levels of care residential
detention Etc which of course is where
um New Hampshire is a lead and continues
to go so with that want to give Jeff a
chance to introduce himself his
background and um his vision and then
leave some time for your
questions yeah thanks so much Marissa
yeah
I you go that's the hardest part of the
job is making sure the lights on and you
know thank you so much yeah and you
couldn't have chosen a better Deputy
Commissioner except I need she was my
boss one of the best boss has ever had
so I hope she gets replaced with someone
uh near to her her leadership skills
yeah um just uh thanks for inviting me
just to spend a couple of minutes with
you um as Marissa said I spent uh 47
years of my career running Community
Based
nonprofits um and the last 38
specifically alternatives to Youth
detention youth incarceration
residential treatment and acute psych
hospitals developing community- based
organizations um and Community Based
plans as an alternative to those
high-end uh at home placements also did
quite a bit of work in gang intervention
in about 30 of our major cities across
the state Chicago Philadelphia Baltimore
um New York New Jersey where I'm from
and many others and also many rural
areas uh in Arizona and Alabama and
Upstate New York and other places so uh
I was very uh interested and I was a big
fan of Joe and um the the amazing array
of services that were built here over
the Last 5 Years millions of dollars in
new programs um that the legislature and
DHHS really developed for our high-risk
kids here in the community so my goal uh
my overwatching goal is to really build
upon the strengths of the of the
existing community-based system of
care um and uh fill in the blanks fill
in the gaps stand it up uh improve upon
it and and make it a a a national model
uh uh for kids and families with the
highest risk of at a home placement by
doing that we have a few major goals
reduce our Reliance on residential
placements maintain maintain a low
census at the
YDC redirect our funds from res from the
residential line to our community line
to strengthen to continue to strengthen
our community based system of care and
Achieve better outcomes for kids and
families particularly those that we've
marginalized pushed out sent out of
state or linger in in in Hamstead or the
d uh the syc so it's really about uh
building upon our current system that
works great for 98% of the kids in our
state and I like to say that we're now
going to build a Continuum for the 2%
the few hundred kids that right now are
not on a track for Success then they
need some really robust interventions
and really robust supports for their
families their Foster families their kin
folks
uh and themselves so Al on there and any
questions um
Weber thank you and welcome um it was it
was a great honor for me to be able to
work with um director ripsom um for some
time when
startlingly all of the people who were
on the um child abuse fatality
commission came from health and Human
Services rather than children and family
law so I had to learn a lot very quickly
um I will also say that I am a casa and
work with children who are stuck in the
system because of abuse and neglect
issues and the one thing I'm sure it is
no news to you but the thing The Plea I
want to make is that um when we have
kids and families that are intact still
that are still with their parents and we
have found a counseling resource for
them my experience is they just begin to
trust a counselor and the counselor goes
somewhere else and you have to start
over again and these are kids and
families that are not programmed to
trust anybody easily so anything that we
can do to promote stability in the
system is a really good thing and I just
put that out there and as I say I know
I'm not telling you anything you don't
already know no that's uh thank you for
that and that's really what you just did
is hit on our main theme um a kid
yesterday uh who's been uh kicked out of
several residential placements in fora
homes said to his worker I have nobody I
have shift workers that come and go I've
been to you know a dozen agencies a
dozen forer homes I don't have anyone to
go to and that's exactly what we want to
do is develop a system of care where
every kid in need has a go-to person
someone who's going to be that as you
said um The Continuous person in their
life that they can trust they can
develop trust that could be their
Advocate could be their Mentor um their
broker of services and they're for them
when they most need them and I think all
of us in this room if we had any trouble
we were growing up they probably because
of where you're all sitting we probably
had someone that helped us along during
very tough times in our careers and in
our lives so that's it you get hit it
right on the head if we can develop
those kinds of systems there's one pilot
that we're now beginning which is a paid
mentorship program right now it's a
pilot so it's reserved for those kids
with the highest need those kids that
are uh lingering uh in our facilities um
don't have uh any connections we're
going to hire paid mentors from the
community where that kid
lives they can work 5 10 15 20 40 hours
a week face Toof face contact with their
young person and their caregiver uh to
really uh provide the robust services
that that kid needs until they're
stabilized then those hours can go down
and then they can uh go into more cruise
control until a crisis hits and then we
can Spike up those hours again so we're
reserving that now for the most uh the
highest need kids the ones most at risk
the kids that have nothing going for
them right this moment so again your
theme is perfect and and that's the
direction we'd love to head
Senator gray um this is part of
preaching to the choir uh but I am an
engineer I usually say I are an engineer
because we're not known for our English
but but you you get what you measure and
the the only part that I would revise in
your statement is keep the number of
people at YDC down okay and what I want
is the appropriate people to have the
services of YDC if that number has to go
up because they need Services that's the
right thing it's not keeping the number
down that is the goal it's the right
Services which comes through in the rest
of your your speech but again I are an
engineer and I decided to say that thank
you yeah no got it yeah we want no kid
should be there doesn't need to be there
if there are other services in the
community so that's more the the way to
frame it so we want to build a frend
system programs to prevent kids from
going in that normally would have gone
in and on the back end a robust after
CARE program so they don't come back
right now 70% of the kids that go to YDC
come back within a year so we want to
change that number um and that's why uh
reduce our Reliance on the YDC but
you're correct kids that need to be
there we hope to have a great trauma
informed small facility to treat those
kids from the chair after the uh scandal
with the facility in Tennessee that um
child advocate Cassandra Sanchez
discovered um there was some quick
putting together rough
legislation and uh would you Deputy
Commissioner would you care to speak to
the the process of bringing this around
to a consensus yeah so um so thank you
and thank you for your leadership in in
convening us around um how to think in
the in in a way that's both strategic
but fundamentally advances our common
agenda around what kids need and and the
need for for strong oversight use of
residential um only in the right cases
and then uh the Assurance of safety at
all times so what I can say is um as you
know we are finishing our review of your
um draft legislation um and thanks to
the way I think that you brought us
together there's a very
interdisciplinary group engaged in that
um both across DHHS as I mentioned
really strong leadership from the
division for Behavioral Health um DCF
but also working directly with the child
advocate um on the 98 again to use to
reuse the 98% metaphor you know really
the vast majority of things we agree on
and want to see um and then um
appreciate your help shepherding that
through the legislative process so a lot
going on even in the last few days and
um and we're feeling feeling good about
and grateful for our involvement in that
the other Fellowship I hold is in child
welfare and what I discovered and when
our cohort last met was Most states have
a dcyf or the equivalent and an office
of child advocate and in many states
they are highly adversarial to each
other and my goal is that we will be
collaborative whenever possible and I
think it will be possible most of the
time and I wish to thank you folks at
dhh plus the office of child advocate
with agreeing with me on that and the
good news is with the deadlines we have
I hope that by the deadline we will be
able to have a revision to the bill is
submitted but if not when it lands
somewhere and it's either going to be
with you or with me next year um there
can be a chance for further tweaking so
I think we're on the road to something
good here and I want to thank your
cooperation very
much anyone else representative Edwards
I I I I'm assuming you don't have any
other remarks that you came ready to
okay so in that case I have uh just sort
of a setup for you um uh in fiscal
committee last week uh there was a
request that the department revisit Dr
Chen's uh letter uh relative to the
summary of coid
research and uh and the reason for the
revisitation
was that it was uh the response that we
got was extremely Broad and it it
basically was a boil the ocean kind of
thing and and because I think the
medical intelligence is suggesting that
Co is not gone and we're going to have
to deal with it again I would like us to
get in in get our front our best foot
forward and be prepared to answer the
question to parents of of whether or not
we can tell them that the clinical
research demonstrates that otherwise
healthy children under the age of 18 or
those who have had a natural immunity
are are good candidates for receiving
the coid um I I think um I you can tell
my bias in my question but I do think
that the DHHS should just have even if
do Chen all he did was saying yes I
think the science demonstrates that
children under the otherwise healthy
children under the age of 18 ought to
get the CO shot Ben Chen then that would
be fine I just want us on record so that
parents know what we're really telling
them yeah yeah thank you for that
comment and um and please know that uh
as a department and also of course our
leadership including Dr Chen and the um
division for Public Health Service
are committed to getting that
communication out in in the channels it
needs I know as a parent of a little one
that I depend on their guidance around
timing and around um this other
information so appreciate it and please
it seeing no further questions thank you
so much both of you for coming we'll see
you
soon the chair recognizes The Honorable
Kendall snow an
alumnus of Health Human Services and
elderly Affairs committee and it is so
good to see you again and I will write
that note if you need pressure so you'll
run again
please thank you very
much and we got to turn the mic on until
we see
the you do you just haven't gotten there
yet I'm sorry and there's a handout
somebody there is a handout yes thank
you it's called
memo thank you very much Mr chairman by
way of introduction I think many of you
know me but I thought I ought to just
say I was very proud just a little
closer to the microphone for my elderly
ears please thank you thank you I I was
very proud to serve as a representative
serving on the health human services and
ELD Affairs committee from 2015 to
2021 and I miss it dearly I'd sincerely
like to come back if I can get the okay
from various people who also have an
influence over my life these days excuse
me could I just get two more copies of
you
there you go I have plenty
I I have
plenty I should also say that for 48
years I served on the staff of the
middle Health Center of Greater
Manchester as a social worker and
Advocate and for the last few years I
was vice president of community
relations and development at that agency
and have a continue interest in the
mental health center and the other
mental health centers in fulfilling
their mission in the New Hampshire and I
stay in touch regularly with the
leadership team that I used to work with
at the sener and at times around other
staff to see what's going on so that I'm
familiar with what's happening I would
like to say that I think it's without a
doubt clear to everyone that the the
federal coid pandemic protective
emergency order that was came into place
in March of 2020 was a very important
public relations of Public Health health
approach to dealing with this massive
pandemic and that came to an end one of
the actions that that order did was
protected the individuals who receiving
Services Under the Medicaid Program to
have the eligibility for Medicaid
protected throughout the period that the
federal order was in place so everyone
who at that time or came into the
Medicaid Program during that protected
period had continuing coverage
unfortunately the protective order did
end on March 31st
2023 and now we're faced with a program
that is now called Medicaid unwind how
do we take people who have been in this
protected status for an extended period
of time and ensure that they still have
the eligibility to receive those
benefits on a continuing basis and it
turned into being a rather uh Monumental
and overwhelming task which I think we
can comment on a little bit more when I
did meet with our people they had some
concerns that I felt I would like to at
least present to you but I Al like to
say that I also am aware that um um
Medicaid
unwind um
is has left some people without benefits
for suspended period while that
eligibility is being redetermined one of
the end results of that has been that
some people being served at the middle
Health Center continue to be served but
we've lost Revenue in rather substantial
amounts uh averaging fair amount as I
indicated in in the memo and the
information that I have only comes from
the experience I glean from the staff at
the mental health center but I'm very
sure that the other mental health
centers are experiencing many of the
same concerns and issues and have some
of the same suggestions I'd like to make
today to how to move this further along
uh and there is an organization called
the New Hampshire Behavioral Health
Association made up of all 10 Community
M Health Centers and they are currently
Gathering Statewide data on this to to I
hope further support the issues that I
bring before you today uh one of the
issues of concerned is over the last 6
months since the protective order ended
uh the the federal order ended uh we've
lost a substantial amount of Revenue
averaging about $250,000 a month now
much of that Reven Vue once the
eligibility is redetermined for all
those people are unaffected and have
their eligibility currently suspended
will return and once their elb
determined are also allowed to
retroactively Bill back to the Medicaid
Program to collect for the services that
we provided before however there is some
issue about what will happen with all
the people who for one reason or another
and there are lots of reasons why they
may not any longer have the same
eligibility that was protected under the
federal order that they will not and
under those people there is no
retroactive payment for the services
that would continue to be provided and
so I guess one of the reasons why I
brought it up was if there's any way to
help some of the mental health centers
deal with this lost Revenue that they
can't now regain the use of uh it would
be appreciated in one memo that I
thought and I don't want to go into
details about what it works but there
are certain patients two-thirds of the
people we serve in Manchester are
considered
State eligible meaning that they served
under a contract that the mental health
centers have with a division of
Behavioral Health at the Department of
Health and Human Services and that
requires that any individual who has one
of the categories of mental illness that
are approved for eligibility under this
state contract as long as the experience
if falls into one of those four state
categories that they're eligible to
receive a capitated grant issued through
the approved by the division of
Behavioral Health and issued through the
uh three Managed Care Organization
administer administer and dispense
Medicaid benefits and
uh there is another part to that which
is that there is a uh maintenance of
effort memorandum that that's out and
each month we have to look at the
capitated rate that's given to each
client and collectively look at did the
amount paid out to the mental health CS
under this capitated rate fall
significantly below looking at the the
whole program that it fall significantly
below what was expected the level of
service that they were supposed to
retain I know this sounds very
complicated when I try to explain it in
very simple terms but in in fact
sometimes there is a payback and one of
the things that we wondered is is there
any way that memorandum or M of effort
uh payback and and and adjustment can be
waved During the period of Medicaid
unwind as all these people get
reestablished with their Medicaid
Eligibility or find out that they're not
going to be any longer Medicaid eligible
I do understand I did forward the
remarks that I gave to you to the
director of the uh the uh Division of
Medicaid services at the Department of
Health and Human Services And he as he
often does responded very quickly to me
about some of the comments that go into
more detail than I could possibly go I
just want you to understand that this
report which is a page and a half long
has to be a gross oversimplification of
the whole Medicaid unwind program I
think it summarizes what goes on but
it's a gross
oversimplification and I I do hope that
some of them uh that I think some of the
details that he outlined to me in his
response to my sending it to him would
be I should also say in terms of my work
with Henry Litman who is the director of
Medicaid services at the division in my
experience with him working with him on
several bills where I was a sponsor or
co-sponsor that pertained to Medicaid I
always found him to be a very competent
fair-minded administrator who was ready
to listen and always ready to consider
any new ideas and was always a reservoir
of information about technical issues
that we need to consider as we made
decisions about these issues
and to give us some feet in the ground
advice about how things might be handled
under difficult circumstances and I
think when he has his chance to come up
later in this uh meeting today he'll
address some of the concerns that you
have and that'll be very hopeful and I
do understand that it's a possibility of
that memori understand that maintenance
of effort understanding may actually be
partially dealt with as I understood it
from his memo which I was not aware of
when I first wrote the memo however it
it would be split but I think the more
we can do to offset that loss of revenue
for the people that we can't
retroactively build for would be helped
second time would you wrap it up and
then we'd like to ask you some questions
will I will I will try to be as fast as
I can I would also like just want to
recognize the hard work and effort put
forth by all the agencies that are
involved including uh Mr litman's
division at the state level uh the the
local district offices the community M
Health Centers and the four manage three
Managed Care organizations that are
dispensing those benefits I do think
that however that uh communication is a
very vital part of making this whole
process work because the process itself
is being added on the ongoing work of
all these agencies in so in addition to
all their regular routine efforts they
have this
added problem added on to how they how
do they go about resolving it it is a
over overwhelming it's times complex
very complicated process that can be
frustrating difficult and um stressful
for everybody involved which can lead to
problems in and of itself but I think
it's very important that we look for
ways to find all four of the elements to
work closely together I have made the
effort to make a few recommendations of
how communication might be facilitated
to do this so that the four parties
could work as closely together as
possible to make make this a reality and
I think under the leadership of the Mr
Litman and the others that I'm quite
confident myself that it's going to work
but it's going to be a long process I
don't know if I need to go through those
four steps I think they're fairly well
detailed in that report but here any
questions please feel free to ask would
anybody have any questions for The
Honorable gentleman uh representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair and it's
really nice to see you back here in this
house The Honorable Mr
K snow this speaks a lot to the issue of
the mental health therapy that's
received by the patient if you will it
does not talk to I think once you go off
Medicaid one of the cornerstones of
mental health therapy has been
pharmaceutical care drug therapy and I
would clim to understand or maybe hear
from you or someone else when they go
off Medicaid what impact does it have
for them because they most likely don't
have access to the pharmacy for the
drugs they need so can you speak to that
impact as far as looking at
pharmaceutical care what this is having
as far as the patient care I understand
why you're asking that question and that
is one of the biggest challenges when
people go off Medicaid and let's face it
even for people who are in that category
called Low utilizers that is people that
move fairly well into their process of
recovery and are doing well certain
maintenance issues have to be maintained
and often that's the maintenance of
medication that helps control the
various symptomss and issues that arise
out the result of their continuing
persistent mental illness and that's a
real Challenge and I I can't go into
great detail about how we do it but we
always are looking for other ways to get
people insured under some of the other
optional
pharmaceutical uh discount programs that
are involved we use free samples that
are given up by the drug companies
wherever we can to augment it we also
look at if there are any other
Alternatives that we could use
in addition to what we're going but it
is an enormous challenge that really
takes an awful lot of thought and effort
on the part of the people providing that
care uh and I I I would also say that
because we have that kind of contact
where we're doing a lot of problem
solving around how do I get my medicine
I'm being told I can't my rent is going
up I have to look for another place to
live can you help me try to locate that
there's a lot of this face-to-face
contact that takes place and of all the
partners that are involved the metal
health centers are the ones that have
the most face-to-face contact with all
these recipients we're often also in a
position to understand some of the
issues that could arise that could
affect in one way or the other what
their eligibility is and as long as we
can get take advantage of that
face-to-face contact to make sure that
information that we may have at our
disposal to pass it along would be very
useful and I think I detail that in my
questions representative Edwards uh
thank you Mr chair uh it's it's good
seeing you again good to see you again
honorable Ken snow um okay so so you
you've always been smarter than I am in
this area and so I'm just I'm just going
to ask you to some make sure my summary
of what you're saying is is accurate and
if it is a yes is fine and if it's no
then maybe you could educate me offline
but um the what I think you're here
asking today is that these suggestions
on the second page that start with
periodic lists and lists provided and
all participants that that these are
really suggestions for the Department
that the department ought to be doing
that and that it sounds like your
request or your ask of the legislature
is to try to find a way to fill uh a gap
for those people who in the Medicaid
unwind who haven't been able to find
Alternative Insurance programs that are
now left naked in the in the insurance
area that we find a way to address that
Gap and I think are those kind of the
two summary points of what you're asking
today yes I I I would agree it is I just
if I could expand upon it just a little
bit I would say that one of the issues
is that I think the information is out
there they have attempted to give lists
but there was another group of people in
addition to the four agencies that are
also somewhat frustrated and and under a
great deal of stress as a result of this
and that is the actual recipients so
sometimes the communication has to be
communicated in such a way that
everybody's kind of on the same page and
uh that's what I'm hoping is that we can
find ways to make sure that that
actually happens I think the division
does the very best they possibly can and
getting that information out as a timely
way as they possibly can but it's it
still becomes a problem I think to do
and if we can find any ways to expedite
that and see all the parties working
more closely together uh and you need to
understand that all four of these
agencies are all frankly under staff we
all have trouble recruiting an adequate
number of people to fulfill all our
ordinary routine responsibilities and to
add this Monumental task on top of it is
a real problem so they're all underst
staffed and under resources they try to
improve communication and communication
is a timec consumer
often frustrating and very stressful
situation that leaves everybody kind of
upset and canly the finger pointing it
you know you don't want to say that
things are moving slowly because of
something I'm doing but it's always easy
to something what somebody else is doing
and I think communication and
appropriate and well understood
communication is the best way to offset
you thank you representative
McDonald thank you Mr chairman uh I
could um I could be wrong about this uh
or and you just mentioned the
communication aspect of things but was
my understanding is unwind was pending
uh as the March 31st deadline was
approaching notices went out encouraging
redetermination and
reapplication um and that's why I'm
wondering what if that uh was a lack of
communication or what contributed to
this backlog and delay in
redetermination can you speak to that
there's a whole host of reasons and I
there's no way I can give you a brief
answer to that the people who had their
eligibility their needs were
communicated directly by the division to
the individuals you need to know who the
individual we are all dealing with
they're all individuals who know very
well that we're obligated to continue to
provide services to them whether or not
we have a resource to pay for those
services or not so a lot of times even
though the communication is sent
directly to them they get very stressed
oh my goodness I'm going to lose contact
with them so the letter often doesn't
really get transported to other people
that they're working with face to face
so sometimes it falls apart at that
level I think I I can't really find any
fault with how they do if you read some
of the letters that go out they're very
fact-based
but for people who are consumers and
even people who are approaching this
kind of problem with a different
perspective like the practitioners out
in the field sometimes those fact-based
letters are a little hard to interpret
so that's why I just stressed if we
could get all the parties working more
closely together and seeing it as a
collaborative as opposed to you do your
job and and I'll do M and eliminate the
possibility of that finger pointing that
I saw as the biggest dilemma that we
have to face and I don't hold anyone at
fault and I for doing it because I think
everybody to some extent is bound to do
it when they're under this much
stress any other questions did I did I
you okay thank you representative uh
once in we hope future yes I I hope so
too I really miss being up here it uh it
was very much uh doing I i' would also
like to thank uh representative Edwards
who was extremely helpful to me in two
of the Medicaid bills that I work he
spent a lot of time working with us and
I think the kind of communication we had
and I found him a real asset to us in
trying to move those forward and I thank
do chair recognizes um Henry Litman uh
Medicaid
yeah good morning um for the record
Henry Lipman the state's Medicaid
director um so I I think what I'm about
to walk through will sort of compliment
a little bit what uh The Honorable
representative snow uh um presented to
you I hope to um share a little bit more
perspective what we have done um to
protect um people but I guess first of
all our goal in in stretching the unwind
was to make sure that anybody who is
eligible for Medicaid um does not lose
it um and those that that can't be
eligible for Medicaid that we look to
try to help them find other sources of
coverage this effort actually um started
in July of 2020 um and we've been
communicating um to
beneficiaries um over a three-year
period before we
began um understanding that at some
point that continuous coverage was going
to end um we started off with a pink
letter Campaign which was you know to
kind of address what um The Honorable
representative snow um referred to some
of the communication challenges we knew
that um it would be beneficial not to
stop our work during the unwind and if
people would voluntarily do their
redetermination ahead of time um we'd
have more capacity to be responsive to
their their needs and um close to 30,000
people took advantage of that um about
10 just under 104,000 did not um but it
it fairly remarkable to get people to do
something when they didn't need to um so
we started off with a pink letter
campaign um and um multiple events uh
you know some having as many as 300
people on conference calls sort of
briefing them about what was going to
happen
we also created incentives in our
Managed Care contract for the mcos to do
Outreach um that continue to the stay in
terms of um reaching their um
individuals and what we actually did is
provided um list to the mcos of the
people who were coming up for
redetermination what they were missing
um to become eligible we also provided
um for this hund roughly 104,000 list to
mental Health Centers federally
qualified Health Centers of their people
who were in that protected status um and
we would update that every month um for
them and with the idea that it's really
uh going to take a community effort to
to try to help some some people so then
we finally get to the point where um you
know Congress took action to create a
definitive end to it we created a yellow
Campaign which was sort of a um a way
Telegraph to to individuals as well as
people might be trying to help them that
um something that is sort of the caution
color pink if you will be a friendly
color yellow be a caution color you know
actually what we had developed there
actually became something that was
adopted nationally by many states in
terms of just a way to rather than the
typical white paper um if you will very
technical things that are required by
law in terms of noticing
um we also then in terms of structuring
the N
wine um did what we called a risk-based
approach which was to to the best of our
ability based on information we had um
have the individuals that were most
likely not to keep coverage be earlier
in the unwine and those that were more
at risk to be later in the unwine um and
I think maybe um you know I think that
probably no state in the country did
more in terms of Outreach to to
individuals despite that there's still
individuals who didn't respond I think
that's I I'll try to get to
representative uh Snow's um uh
recommendations at the end of terms I
think what more can be
done well while you're taking a breath I
will repeat that you're a groupy to uh
the Medicaid uh directors around the
country I know because that came up in
one of my fellowships and somebody said
oh New Hampshire Henry Litman I said you
mean the Henry Litman and they said yeah
so continue thank you um just to kind of
give you a snapshot where we're at the
third uh slide and um kind of gives you
a high level view of where we are as of
this past
Monday um you know New Hampshire's um
total enrollment grew to
21,35 that's the number on the top right
of that slide um and you can see if you
look uh to your left the granted
Advantage Program Medicaid expansion
grew to almost 97,000 individuals at its
peak in March um we had typically been
running in the low 50,000 uh um so in
terms of looking at where we are today
in granted Advantage we're we're almost
for you know just under 39,000 less
individuals in the
program
um in terms of of that program that
that's largely an income based program
so that um you know if you look at why a
lot of people qualified there the shock
of the the some of the closures or
partial closures in the system led to a
lot of people being unemployed for a
short period of time and there was an
opportunity to to gain health coverage
where you may have lost it through your
employer um and then for you know just
basically three years we we didn't go
through the normal annual process of
checking people's eligibility we are now
required to do so
and um you know that drop and enrollment
in that group isn't I think totally be
unexpected some of those individuals
could be um folks that were in the
Community Mental Health Center uh system
but if they're income ineligible there's
not much that we can do directly what we
did do though however is um for IND we
were um the first and only state so far
in the country that developed a a pilot
program with um ciia which is the agency
that oversees the the exchanges and we
actually
transferred um about a little over
20,000 uh maybe close to 24,000
individuals uh to The Exchange about
half of those would have otherwise gone
nowhere under the old system where um so
that they had the chance to not only
have communication from us but
communication from the New Hampshire
Navigators and federal government to
make them aware of the opportunity to
get coverage um you know federally um we
also you know in the whole effort um
made phone calls to every every
household um and the ones with the most
vulnerable more than once um during this
effort to alert them um and and despite
that there there are people who probably
may still be eligible that that are but
one of the things I highlighted in
conversation with former representative
snow is that um New Hampshire adopted
one of the federal flexibilities
ordinarily someone um has 90 days to ask
for
reconsideration um the federal
government offers 120 days for States
during this unwind period we adopted
that so someone may have lost
coverage um if it's less than 120 days
out they actually can get retroactive
coverage to be put on Medicaid that's
one of the things I think that one of
the efforts that can be made at this
point is that probably most of the
higher risk people are more currently
have lost coverage um and there's an
opportunity to to bring them back on um
I think that everybody could redouble
their efforts um in that regard the
other thing we've done is every month um
we started this in June which is just
two months into it when we saw people
who had high Medical utilization or risk
we um the Medicaid administrative team
made additional phone calls to these
people to see what they whether they
knew that they got the paperwork whether
they were in process um we've made
almost 2,000 calls of that type and
we've reached over 700 people um to
speak to them um you know on top of what
we're doing um in terms of all the
notifications um but I do think that
we're right in the period now where it's
really important that you know there's
still a Lifeboat out there and um we
ought to try to be working um you know
as collaboratively can with both the
mcos and the uh cmhc's and others just
think what you could accomplish if you
had an adequate staff in terms of
numbers huh well um you know I think
that um everybody's pitched in more and
and you know people worked um you know I
think uh representative Edwards asked me
the question you know can we sustain the
effort through the through the unwind
you know a few months ago and I we you
know people have stepped up to to work
extra where we've had vacancies to to
make sure that we get done what we need
to get done um this slide four in the
deck is really um a summary of how we
sort of structured who went first in
this effort
um uh slide uh five I think gets to kind
of the the concept that I'm trying to
suggest is real where the opportunity
lies today that what we've seen and when
we report statistics we're reporting
them on in the current month um for the
month that they're due but what we're
also tracking is whether they reopen
later and so um there's three statistics
here I won't read it read them all to
you but um there are people here um that
are able to come back on um and when you
consider the various categories the
percentage is actually fairly um you
know high and worthwhile to to go
after uh in addition um and the next
slide excuse me yeah which is slide six
is we um during the process of reaching
out and calling people we also had um
almost um 6% of the individuals or 7% of
the closures actually were people who
told us when we reached out to them do
you still need Medicaid um told us they
didn't you know they found other sources
of coverage some people you know there
were some reported deaths in the
population um but you know we did um
this work I think again is unique I've
been other states have reached out to me
um Missouri I think it is most recently
about how we did this um and it was a
combined effort of the department and
the mcos in that
regard um slide seven is kind of what's
what's our statistics that are reported
federally um and what we keep separately
um Orient you a little bit to this chart
I think there are really three sections
the the column that's titled grand total
is what are the public facing statistics
that CMS will ultimately report on the
month we divide it between what we call
the protected population and the
nonprotected population as I mentioned
before the protected population was
about 100 104 just under 104,000 people
the balance are what we call
nonprotected meaning that they were
never subject to that that that coid
situation in terms of having continuous
coverage they're going through an annual
process and renewal process and the the
slide on that I have up first here on
slide seven is the month of September
what we've seen over time is that based
on our structuring of the unwine that as
we expected to go further into it the
people who we were trying to protect the
most were like more likely to keep
coverage and that's exactly what we're
seeing in the statistics in both the
protected and the nonprotected uh
categories if you look at sort of the
flesh tone um part there that
uh for the month of September that you
know 79% overall retain
coverage and that's broken down in
between the protected group the people
that had the coid
protections and the nonprotected group
which are people coming through their
routine um that next
section is the um the area where um the
uh nonprocedural
um yeah the procedural folks are the
ones that are with that special pilot
which would have otherwise dead lettered
meaning nothing would have happened to
them um and so those have been referred
to the federal government for further
work and work by our local Navigators
and then um an additional level of
detail that we provide um down the
bottom which isn't federally disclosed
but we've been looking at is what were
the reasons for the closures you know
was it income was it that they failed to
to
redetermined at this point to to uh to
complete their
redetermination um the next slide down
to eight is sort of the cumulative
effort um
and here again I think that earlier on
in the campaign if you will um
individuals loss coverage were more due
to income that those were the people
that we had a good indication or were
over income based on information we had
okay I'm getting the move it along um
then the next slide um is uh what we've
done to
um to
uh make it easier on people um and terms
of when we have enough information to
determine their eligibility without them
submitting additional information um
we've made adjustments in policy both
what CMS allows and what basically how
we structured the population which has
led to the more recent months where the
most vulnerable people are that we've
been more often been able to um do a
review without them even requiring their
paperwork in in the upcoming month of
November it will be 74% of the
population will be renewed without
having to go through the torturous
process of completing the
application um slide 10 is just a kind
of where we're at we're about 97%
through the unwind as of of today we're
but we're really slowing down a lot now
because we got the and extended the
period all the way out to to May for the
in it's small numbers but it's the
really most vulnerable people um you
know people at are home and based uh and
nursing homes and such that they we
really see that they need more help than
than some of the people earlier um and
then um the last slide I have is just
some a summary of a sort of our call
campaign that extra effort we make when
we see each month the people that uh um
have medical conditions showing up in
claims that suggest that they need some
additional
Outreach so I guess to to make a longer
story short um we're certainly open to
working with the Community Mental Health
Centers further um I think it's not
something the department can control
it's something that everybody's got to
make their best contribution to it the
mcos the um you know when people come in
you know um if they have a um authorized
rep relationship with them they can do a
lot to see what's going on um the mcos
even one of the mcos has developed a
lookup file where people can check um
their members uh we
we're we're in the process now with
regular renewals we it's a dynamic
changing group of populations so we
can't produce the same kind of reports
we could when it was a static
population will you take questions
please sure and last thing on the
maintenance of effort if I could uh is
that there is in our contract currently
with the mcos a a 50% disregard if um
they don't make the the the number of
visits and such that they should um
under their contracts um which we've had
in place for quite a bit of this
contract and we're evolving the contract
and the reprocurement um to a very
different system um that will be helpful
to the m to the Community Mental Health
Centers chair recognizes representative
Edwards thank you Mr chair uh fir first
Mr Litman I I just want to um take the
chance to uh congratulate you and your
team again on outstanding implementation
of the new Medicaid rates reimbursement
rates um it it turned out to be a far
more complex project than what we had
assumed in the legislature and you guys
brought in your actuaries and did all
the community outreach and it was just
it's the only thing I've ever gotten
somebody from the community to call me
and tell me how great it was so normally
people call me to complain but that was
great um a a small thing
as I look at page and you don't have to
address this but just to let you know as
I'm looking at uh page seven under um
total closure by reasons I look at
failed to uh
redetermined the graph presentation of
that on slide 10 bottom left hand it it
looks like the data is different and the
graph doesn't present as I would have
expected yeah so I just would say if
this is public facing you may want to
have somebody just double check that
yeah I and I'm I'm confident the numbers
it's just it's a different kind of look
that the the stuff that's in the table
is sort of a um what's done and what you
see in um the the bar chart is sort of
forward looking we're looking at October
and November um uh okay so that's a
future State yep okay um and then my may
I and then my favorite question to you
now that we're sort of so far along in
terms of um having the Medicaid contract
renewed uh are are you uh confident that
we're going to have at least three mcos
at the end of the day and I know you're
limited to what you can say because it's
proprietary but if you could just kind
of indicate whether you think uh we're
at risk well I think one of the
questions you've asked me in the past is
you know what is going to be the
enrollment um figure that because you
need about 50 60,000 per MCO to make it
worth a while to be in the market in
terms of being able to compete um I
think that you know right now we're at
um just a little bit above where we were
um last time we went out for procurement
there are several policies that are in
hp2 that we're in the process of
implementing which will have some effect
of marginally increasing enrollment that
was the postpartum coverage uh that went
into effect um 101 uh effective January
1 is the for the legally residing
pregnant women and children but probably
the larger one is a federal requirement
that um all states have to adopt which
is children have to have 18 and under
have to have 12 months of continuous
coverage and so um that I think will
have an effect of making the market just
a little bit more attractive I I do
think that will have three um mcos
through we have all through uh Amendment
um excuse me the what I'll call contract
number two the fiveyear period that ends
uh this August and I I suspect that
we'll continue to to have
uh thank you again great work on on the
Medicaid reimbursement rate adjustments
thank you thank you and thank you Mr
Litman look forward to your occasional
updates happy to do so and I think uh Dr
finny's here to do a little bit on the
checkup on our dental program something
we will get our teeth
mouth um we went 10 minutes without a
dad joke what do you mean okay yes hi
good
morning um Dr Sarah finny Medicaid
dental director um thank you very much
for allowing me to have some time this
morning to bring you up to date on the
adult Dental benefit um I believe you
have a
handout um I want to start off with
really the most important thing and that
is um how many of our members are
getting Services because that's what
this whole thing is really all about and
I'm happy to say that between April 1
which was our implementation date and
now we have had over 8,000 unique
members served um through the denal
program and uh the vast majority of
those have had more than one appointment
but this is one of the things that we
track um to really see how things are
going um in these early days of the
program so so Dr Finny just so I
understand the graph this is this is
each month this is not cumulative um the
graph is is each month and 8,000 is the
cumulative number of unique patients
overall um you'll see that there's a a
steady increase in the number of members
as well as claims with a slight dip in
July which is very normal um I've seen
that with my experience and the
children's benefit um you know providers
and members are alike are not at work
and at home um and that's to be expected
uh we do have a little bit of a claims
lag usually two to three months so
September um when we pulled these
numbers we we know that we still
probably don't have all of the September
claims so when I report to you again um
that will show
the correct amount and I I do believe
that we are seeing steady growth month
over month and the preliminary uh
numbers that I have for October show
that um to be true I think it's
important um to point out at this point
that both Northeast Delta and deltaquest
are engaging with providers to make sure
that um they understand how the claims
process is working in this program and
they are training providers and their
office staff so that claims processing
goes through um
expeditiously and they're also reaching
out to support members to as an an
effort in recruitment to show that they
really are dedicated to making sure that
there is minimal administrative burden
for our
providers and then one little um piece
of information that I wanted to share
because I think it it is a concern that
we all had going into this out of of the
39 oral surgeons that are practicing in
New Hampshire 20 are enrolled in this
benefit and that speaks to the
recruitment efforts that have gone on
and I'm very happy with that and
recruiting is still going on that that
has not stopped it will not stop and um
program um that leads nicely into the
next page which is the actual Network um
dashboard so we have 142 unique members
at 103 unique locations as I said 20 of
those were oral surgeons and that is at
20 different
locations um we also are taking
advantage of some providers along our
borders who do have experience um in the
past um they have treated our Medicaid
adults um when they just had the
emergency benefit and you know uh we
have added them to the the network
because that's an important piece for
some of our residents who are at the
border and that may actually be the most
um convenient location for them we also
do provide a breakdown um there are 10
providers who are take five which means
that they've agreed to take on five
members see how it goes and um you know
the idea is that with the support that
Quest is providing uh for
administration uh that that will lead to
them actually seeing more members 57 are
off
directory uh and 41 member um providers
are seeing their existing patients which
means they had adults that were in their
practices who were Medicaid eligible um
and they are maintaining them in the
practice and and treating them now under
the new benefit and then um currently 11
are treating special needs patients only
to the far right is the breakdown by
County um and I I will say that
recruitment efforts are driven by our
priority area needs so as new dentists
enroll and drop into that breakdown it
will change the emphasis on on what
areas um are more active in
recruitment so there's a lot of of
movement um it's all positive movement
and we are adjusting as we go um I do
want you to know that our frequency of
meetings with North East Delta and denta
Quest has not slowed down from our
implementation practice I am not
exaggerating when I tell you I have at
least one meeting a day that involves
something to do with the adult program
because we are focused on making sure
that it is functioning the way that it
was meant
to um the next page um goes into our
mobile dental clinics which is another
critical piece of the network we realize
that there are certain areas of the
state where we may never have the bricks
and mortar dental offices to really take
care of our members and so we're using
mobile services to fit into the network
so that we're getting services to those
areas um this schedule changes um this
schedule looks slightly different than
it did last week and part of that was
based on demand um I'm happy to say that
uh this weekend Saturday and Sunday the
mobile van will be in lonia at Health
First and they have a very robust
schedule on Saturday there will be two
dentists working there and they have 20
patients scheduled and on Sunday there
will be one dentist there and they have
12 patient scheduled um and that's what
we're aiming for when the van goes out
to a site we want to make sure that that
chairs are filled and that time is being
used efficiently to best serve um our
members in those areas and the mobile
services are not oneandone uh they are
definitely planned um with a certain
frequency we want to make sure that
those services are are available on an
ongoing basis and so you'll see um as
the schedule develops that we do go back
to the same locations month month after
month and that is to make sure that not
only are Urgent needs taken care of but
those members are getting ongoing
services that they
need and then the last um part of the
program that I think is also very
important is uh stakeholder engagement
with various organizations and agencies
across the state Northeast Delta and
denta Quest have taken very seriously um
um their the importance of them being
involved with outside organizations to
really get at what our members needs are
how do we best serve them how do we
support the dental providers and the
network so that they can serve members
effectively and to that end um there are
there are items that um specify really
for dentists including oral surgeons and
as I mentioned earlier there is uh
one-on-one recruitment Outreach still
ongoing across the state um the team
from Den Quest and and Delta is involved
in different conferences and educational
opportunities that are going on
regarding oral health across the state
probably one of the most um helpful
things that they have done the team goes
out to the New Hampshire Dental Society
component meetings every fall the latest
um president of the dental Society goes
out and meets at each of the nine
components and that is a perfect um
opportunity to meet dentists in a a
small setting it allows for
conversations and um I would say that um
that has been an important part of
recruitment is getting the word out um
not only from uh the side of Northeast
Delta and den Quest but also to speak to
dentists that are already providers and
can speak to how things are going and
hopefully encourage other dentists to
enroll as well um and the team is also
involved with the New Hampshire oral
health Coalition and all of the things
that they are working on so they're
really trying to connect at many
different
levels um the team also is meeting with
nursing facilities we have bimonthly
meetings with the nursing home
Association which allows for a back and
forth conversation we get real- time
information about how things are working
possibly where we need to make some
adjustments and making sure that we
understand the needs of our residents
who are in nursing facilities because
their needs are definitely going to be
different than a lot of our other
members um and that conversation
includes working with the transportation
vendor because we know that that's an
important piece of um the benefit
there and then lastly the the special
needs population um is one that we're
really trying to make sure that we have
not only the Prov ERS available that
feel comfortable and ready to treat
those members but also to give them
support training continuing education
that will allow them to continue to do
so and again also to introduce other
dentists who may not have considered um
that they were ready or able uh to treat
that
population AEL New Hampshire started up
an oral health task force within the
last several months and um our team
attends those meetings that has been a
wonderful place to really talk with
individuals that have special needs and
learn about what their past experiences
have been um attending Dental
appointments and what are the things
that really make or break that
relationship for them and we can learn a
lot from that group we also work with
area agencies uh we're working with the
UNH Institute on disability they
actually have a training module for um
um medical professionals to work with
special needs individuals they have act
they're very excited um about the adult
benefit and they would like to actually
try to do a second version of that
training module that is very specific
for dentists and so we're working with
them to develop that that will be
something um that can be done um online
at the convenience of providers um and
is meant to really be supportive and to
lead to um an increased uh enrollment
with these dentists and then um we're in
the early stages of discussion with an
organization called special Smiles which
actually originates out of New Jersey um
they have a whole program um that
they're very versed in treating special
needs individuals who need anesthesia
and so again it's just another um
organization that can help us to learn
what it is that we need to provide um
what what supports are out there so
we're not recreating the wheel here in
New Hampshire if there are programs that
we can um gain information from you know
we're trying to do that um and I will
take any questions any questions
representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair thank you Dr
VY for taking my question um one of the
things talked about before is the issue
of Nosh shows and what impact it will
have on providers and my understanding
is that a no-show is not being
compensated by the program so are we
tracking or somehow tracking Nosh shows
to ensure that we're not having a
situation where the providers are not
getting compensated because once they
book the time they can't rebook it very
good question and uh yes we are
addressing that there are codes um there
are dental um codes that track that and
uh what Dent Quest is doing uh is
monitoring when those codes come in and
they go to see who the member is that's
involved and there is Outreach directly
to the member to get out what the reason
is um that they were unable to make
their appointment and this plays in with
why we in felt it was so important to
include Care Management in this plan and
also the
transportation Mr
chair follow uh follow up thank you sir
is it possible to get a chart of how
that's going over time is it increasing
decreasing remaining stable is a way to
get some sort of documentation data I
can certainly get that information if if
I could just tag on to that comment uh
tag that that was uh that was one of the
questions I was going to ask U but uh if
you if you're going to provide us that
graph it might be useful to be able uh
if you're able to Benchmark against like
the commercial or the private pay no
show rate because I think the extent to
which our program has a higher or lower
no-show rate than private pay that that
is a a significant red flag if we've got
a a problem to to address so okay uh and
then uh I follow up I I I I want to tell
you that uh the way you're managing this
program is U far more complex and is
greater than what representative Shapiro
and I imagined when we first started you
know bouncing this around so I want to
thank you for the maturity and
development of this program it's great
uh I'm I'm looking at slide three under
the county breakdown on the network
dashboard yes and there's a pre-f
flating arrow there I don't know if that
arrow is meant to indicate that bellnap
is a concern no as as I look at it uh I
it looks to me like Sullivan is a
concern my apology is that Arrow it was
meant to connect the total unique
providers and locations like look over
here this is the county breakdown and it
should not have been aimed at it should
have been aimed at okay no no SWAT but
um but so then my real question there is
um under this management by exception
principle if if you think Sullivan
County for example is the county that we
should be focused on and worried about
and everyone else is okay it would be
good to know where where your where your
big red flags are in the state um I
would say that Sullivan right now is
probably um the biggest concern and we
have a tremendous amount of Outreach
going on to
determine you know where are the folks
really residing how far are they having
to go because there are several Prov you
know two providers there um so that is
an area of concern and that's why that
has now been added into the schedule for
the mobile services because we realize
we need to do something right now um
while we're continuing to recruit more
providers thank
you representative
Weber thank you and my apologies for
coming in late um I just had one quick
question on the provider on the county
breakdown um I see that chesher county
is in there twice once once with five
and once with three and I'm
wondering why chesher is there twice one
with five and one with three and I I
assumed maybe it meant that people were
going out of state to Vermont but I see
that that's broken out separately I will
ask these number this was provided by D
Quest I will ask them about that and my
apologies for not C and just my personal
curiosity because that's my County thank
you before you leave I um made the de
developmentally disabled Community one
of my interests when I first ran for the
house uh 7 and a half years ago and I
just want to say that the feedback I get
from them appreciates your visits uh
they are very happy for that so thank
you and thank you both all right thank
you uh lest I forget at the and uh our
next meeting because the fourth Friday
is the day after Thanksgiving and we're
all asleep from trip toan our next
meeting will be on November the
17th the third Friday and when we go to
third Friday that's 1 p.m. not in the
morning because of some other groups
morning thank you
yes looking at the calendar again in
December it looks like I am about to say
that there is some question as to
whether we should meet um in December if
we did it would be the 15th at 100 p.m.
and given the number of items that need
to be presented to us I would be in
favor of meeting in December and if you
wish privately to email me and let me
know what you think um if I have two
lists and one says five and the other
says three I will conclude that's eight
like jeser County uh Mr chair yes I just
want to let you know if my ankle is
holding up and improving I I will be out
of state on the 17th okay well we promis
not to have too much fun then okay next
annual report on the implementation of
New Hampshire's 10-year Mental Health
Plan Julian carbin deputy director
division for Behavioral Health Rebecca
Ross director Bureau for children's
Behavioral Health both at the
welcome and we have a nice juicy report
from you yes we have packets on the
tables for um for the annual report and
as you can see from so good morning my
name is Julian carbin the deputy
director for the division for Behavioral
Health joined by my colleague Rebecca
Ross the director for the Bureau for
what speak closer
closer thank you welcome thank you so
it's a pleasure to have an opportunity
to speak with you this morning regarding
the 10e mental health plan as you can
see from the report a lot of progress
has been made uh since the report was
published in 2019 this morning we just
want to go through a few of the
highlights um in the report from the
last
year
so we'll start in the area um of in
terms of the goal for expanded
coordination of our Continuum of Care
and we really want to highlight the
progress that's been made through the
state's New Hampshire rapid response
crisis
system as you're all aware we've created
a centralized crisis contact center that
within the last year and a half it's
responded to over 40,000 calls and
deployed mobile crisis response teams
over 9,000 times to respond to children
youth amilies and adults in the
need um since June of 20122 we've also
expanded critical time intervention to
be a Statewide service and that program
is an evidence-based practice that
supports adults through transitions of
care and for many of the adults serve
through this program they're hitting the
mental health system or experiencing the
mental health system for the first time
and this program really helps to provide
um targeted concentrated support to help
that transition from the hospital from a
designated receiving facility back into
the community to be better coordinated
and more integrated um to help their
success in the
community another area we want to
highlight is in the area of prevention
and early intervention so I'll turn that
over to
Rebecca thank you Julian good morning um
we did want to highlight that we have
been able to expand our Care Management
entity Services through the Early
Childhood wraparound services is similar
to fast forward but this service focuses
on um the birth to five population as
well as the caregiver needs and while we
launched it with our um first Services
last July this July 1 we were able to
receive Medicaid approval um for it to
be a covered benefit through Medicaid um
and really Innovative in that it is
based on um needs and caregiver needs in
order to prevent or address Aces before
we're deeper in the system and we're the
first state to have had CMS approval for
that type of Medicaid benefit that is
very much prevention focused on Early
Childhood so that 10 years from now
we're not having the same conversations
system and lastly we wanted wanted to
recognize um the work taking place to
address Workforce challenges um just
recognizing the need to proactively
build uh our Workforce capacity the
department has been working on several
initiatives to create new career
Pathways into the mental health system
so for example we worked in partnership
with our community mental health centers
and New England College to create a new
Bachelor level uh Cooperative learning
program where students are able to
enroll in the class as well as work for
the Community Mental Health Center under
supervision and provide services uh to
their local community we've also been
working in partnership with the college
system to create new certification
programs one is for our peer certified
Specialists and the second is for
specialty crisis responder certification
program and both of those certification
programs we anticipate rolling out
through the Community College network in
early
2024 so you know in addition to to to
new career um Pathways new career
programs a lot of effort and funding has
been invested in training for our
current Workforce both to increase their
competencies and specialized services in
in an effort to cross train staff as
well as to have a focus on improving job
satisfaction and retention within our
community mental health
centers so that's a very high level
overview I mean as you can see from the
report a lot of progress has been made
um and as we look forward to 2024 the
department continues to be focused on
these priorities and goals within the
tenure Mental Health Plan um that are
outlined in the in the cover letter so
we're open to questions as you have them
anyone
anyone representative Edwards we have to
question because I can't help
myself okay so this is all a very
positive thing you've told us right and
and today's theme for me is management
by exception so is there something going
on that we should know about that you're
you're just a little concerned about in
terms of the development of the 10-year
plan or I mean you're very positive
there's got to be something broken
somewhere that's why you know we have
the plan before us I I think what's
positive is that we have a clear
strategy the challenges are are
absolutely embedded in this cover letter
in terms of this is why we are focusing
on these areas there are concerns around
access to care that really is rooted in
the availability of of Workforce those
are the significant challenges that
we're seeing in our system is um being
able to find and retain enough workers
to provide the services that have been
invested in and stood up around the
state for example you've heard us say
before that the mobile crisis system is
staffed at about 50% capacity and other
programs are seeing similar Staffing
patterns thank you and thank you for
you the chair recognizes Wendy Alman
bureau chief Bureau of elderly and Adult
Services on a review of the draft plan
public awareness campaign on brain
dementias
and we are only four minutes running
late due to again uh attorney Williams's
wonderful
timeline is the hand something already
handout I don't think it's that I think
know
good
morning good morning for the record my
name is Wendy Alman and I am the bureau
chief for the Bureau of elderly and
Adult Services at
DHHS I am here today to talk about the
plan that uh the department has for
engaging in a public awareness campaign
for all Alzheimer's disease and related
dementias as a result of House Bill 2
the department was uh mandated to put
forward a plan for a public awareness
campaign and a uh process for procuring
uh a vendor in order to carry out that
plan so in front of you I have an
executive summary providing overview of
um why we are doing this and our intent
as well as a high level timeline which
includes some of the activities um that
we are planning over this the course of
the next
baym um and on the other side of the the
plan we have provided a draft of several
of the deliverables that will be
required as part of the procurement um
for a vendor for this public awareness
campaign as well as the reporting and
monitoring outcomes which as part of the
legislation um described that our our
plan and our public awareness campaign
needed to include um and I'll just
provide a high Lev overview of the
timeline and
activities and talk a little bit about
those deliverables and then be able to
take any questions so I'm happy to say
after today we've completed the first um
set of activities as part of this plan
um in July we began meeting and working
with our partners with the Alzheimer's
Association as well as the New Hampshire
Commission on Aging on um implementing
an outline and a framework for our
process and our plan plan and we have
been working internally at the
department to develop the
RFP um and work with Finance in order to
make sure that we've put our package
together in order to put out a
procurement um for this
vendor and we are working with the all
armers Association and the New Hampshire
Commission on Aging aging on the
development of the the plan that you see
in front of you um and we will continue
to work with them during the procurement
process starting in November we will be
following up with the contracts unit or
basically after today we'll be working
with them in order to get the
procurement released um and then we will
go through that procurement process and
then begin working with a with a vendor
um once we're able to get the contract
approved um starting in February we hope
to be working with that vendor um and
having kickoff meetings coordinating
with those named Partners as part of the
legislation and others um within the
department and as part of our
stakeholder uh and provider Partners um
in order to be able to deliver the work
and have a campaign launch and then be
monitoring and overseeing the activity
as well as beginning to formulate what
we will be providing as a report um in
terms of our outcomes um and the related
deliverables and perhaps even next steps
and I'd like to say also that we're
monitoring this work and activity as
part of our state plan on U and we will
be um including uh our goals and
objectives related to our state plan in
terms of age friend language and working
with our stakeholders and partners in
order to make sure that the work that
we're doing intersects with this
campaign and can benefit from
it in terms of deliverables we are
hoping to develop a
comprehensive multi-mod marketing
campaign um in terms of public awareness
related to brain health and Al
Alzheimer's disease we also hope to
um develop and utilize a different
differentiated campaigns that look at
other Target audiences and expand um our
Statewide effort um we will collaborate
with Community Partners and leaders in
order to extend the reach of the
messaging that we hope to
accomplish and uh in intend to uh look
at different models of being able to
look at the the reach that we have
whether that's um through uh multimedia
uh platforms as well as um accessible
platforms for for
individuals um and another important
part of this plan is the reporting and
monitoring and we want to be able to
ensure that we are uh monitoring our
vendor and working with them so we will
be doing quarterly work plan um updates
and deliver
and monitoring the
budget and learning from this as well as
looking at the number of individuals who
are going to be reached um through this
paid these paid media efforts and our
stakeholder Community feedback and
fiscal reports we will be um partnering
with those uh the Alzheimers Association
and the New Hampshire Commission on
Aging to give them regular updates I am
currently the Department of Health and
Human Services representative to the New
Hampshire Commission on Aging so I will
be um actively involved in making sure
our the rest of the commission members
are aware of the work that we're doing
and we can engage with them to answer
any questions that they have throughout
the process um we do intend to put
together a final status report that we
will come back to the um oversight
committee to present um and be able to
answer questions and um certainly if
there are any recommendations or
outcomes to this that may lead to um
future activity or requests um we will
involve the Alzheimer Association and
the New Hampshire Commission on Aging as
a result of that and we'll make sure
that it's um compatible or comports with
their goals and objectives as as
Weber thank you uh I didn't see that
coming I thought you were lateraling in
the other direction but um you were te
thank you for taking my question
um I'd love to hear a little more
specifically how the Outreach is going
to happen
are we talking advertisements are we
talking um social media are we talking
television I I just you know I gather
it's multimodal I gather that it's in
operating in a number of different ways
but I just want to know
specifically what you're thinking about
and I realize that will depend to some
extent on what you and a a contractor
come up with in in both the um
Contracting process and then and and
developing the campaign but what do you
have in in your thoughts as to the
precise methods of
communication thank you for the question
um we do expect to outline uh a a high
level overview of the types of um
Outreach and media Camp public awareness
campaign activities um that we would
like to see with the funding that we
have um appropriated for this project
project as part of the request for
proposal we will be asking the vendor to
propose um a budget as well as
uh in terms of being able to meet the
goals of Statewide activity and reaching
all of the different audiences that we
have um coming up with a plan that will
include both I Envision um TV radio um
social media as well as um paper and
other accessible modes of doing Outreach
um we will be asking the vendor to do uh
F some focus groups and engaging the
public um in terms of what they would
like to see or how it will um penetrate
uh the population that we want to serve
um through this public awareness
campaign so I anticipate there may be
things that um they will propose that we
um don't don't know yet you know there
there may be strategies um because I'm
and we're working with our public
information office too so we will be
partnering um with the vendor um with
this representative uh
Merchant thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my
question thank you for what you're doing
it's important work
work there's also a subcommittee of this
committee dealing with Alzheimer can you
explain to the committee how that
subcommittee is going to intersect with
the work here that you're doing um where
is that intersection going to occur and
what is going to be come of
it thank you for that question I um in
my position I've been um newly nominated
to sit on that subcommittee and I am
waiting information in regards to
scheduling of those subcommittee
meetings and we'll be um as part of that
process I imagine that we will be
discussing this plan and giving regular
updates um to that subcommittee as well
thank you representative
Edwards uh thank you Mr chair and and
thank you for this report uh Miss Alman
um I I for the mostly for the Committees
purpose and if I misstate this you know
correct me um this this uh program was
initially identified uh and put into
legislation um and the initial draft of
the legislation wasn't um particularly
comprehensive in terms of the extent of
what we would expect and I think we went
back and we worked it with the lobbyist
and probably back with Miss ultman and
uh really appreciate the level of
specificity this is about the right
level for the legislature to know that
you are spending the
$500,000 well because that was the
initial concern the legislation was so
ambiguous we didn't know what we were
going to get for half a million dollars
so this is reassuring thank you thank
you for that work um I I I'd also like
to just point out for the for the uh
mostly for the executive for for the
committee here that um Public Health has
the mission of providing public facing
education the topic of Alzheimer and
dementia has been on the radar for many
many years and because Public Health got
just just was never able to get to it we
thought the special effort was
appropriate and as I understand it when
we get these deliverables and
programmatics set up the responsibility
to sustain it will shift from you over
to Public Health is is that true is that
is that's what I understood the plan to
be well we haven't discussed uh
sustainability of any um ongoing
Outreach or public awareness but I can I
know from my perspective we partner very
closely with the division of Public
Health and population Health we're um
engaging in activities related to um
age-friendly Public Health Systems um
and brain health um and we're
coordinating with them to ensure that
we're collecting data and information
related to Alzheimer's disease and
related dementias in the state um
through some of their data collection
purposes so we've set the stage really
for um future engagement and
sustainability of this kind of
work followup so so this is actually
from Miss hen this is a just a comment
um that uh one of the concerns when we
looked at the legislation around this
was the potential redundancy and it's
great to go ahead and do a new program
in the department that it's supposed to
be in for the subject matter expertise
but I I i' hate to have us come back in
two or three budgets from now and see
that we've got redundant public
awareness uh organizations so if you all
could just pay attention to what what's
the right degree of redundancy and
what's the right degree of um alignment
great good thank you and thank you thank
you very much uh as we close uh next
meeting will be November 17th at 1 p.m.
we've got some fun things scheduled um
update on protocols for complaints and
investigations with the Board of
Medicine you may remember former
representative Solway and I basically
co-chaired a subcommittee of this group
to look into that October of a year ago
uh also the DD and ABD waight list
quarterly report will be up next month
also report regarding the use of
restraint and different modes of
transportation of pay patients to New
Hampshire hospital and designated
receiving facilities that's something
that we really want to be very U
cognizant of it's an important issue
there's other things as well but those
are just three highlights uh those of
you who uh know of a subcommittee in law
that has been dormant and you want to
reactivate it get in touch with me I
know there's a few people interested
that we would start a new subcommittee
again uh let me see some developments on
that and possibly we will have a meeting
on the 15th of December at 1 pm let me
know and since we started 2 minutes late
the chair declares we ended one minute
early thank you Mr chair did you need a
motion to adjourn because I I still had
one more comment for you no we don't
need a motion to okay we've got we've
got syney here and an area agency and
the BDS I don't know if any of them had
wanted to say anything we're okay on
that representative thank you we'll hear
them next month all right Mr chair yes
as far as the next meeting there was
some discussion by represent Weber to
either go a little longer or holding
additional meetings in a month may I
suggest to the chair and the rest of the
committee that we try out in November
15th to go a half hour
longer I'm sure that attorney Williams
will find a few things to add to the
agenda thank you let's try that see how
15th